so at some of the organizations that I
think you've worked with
finance to fund low-cost schools I'm in
Ghana and can you tell us a little bit
more about that and if you think that
there are other kinds of institutions
that microfinance could partner with
synergistically that way in the future
that's a great question I so our program
that we are working on in Ghana is
basically using microfinance and
microfinance products to improve schools
and so we work with this kind of little
known sector of these low-cost private
schools that actually focus on deprived
communities so where they're either is
no government school or the government
school is too far away or it's over
crowded you know members of the
community just sort of set up their own
school and they charge a you know an
affordable tuition to the parents these
are basically not for-profit schools and
so there are some for-profit schools but
we focus on not for-profit schools and
then you know they use that tuition to
pay the teachers and run the school but
technically they're a business and so
like any business they might need a loan
to grow because even though their
schools they don't get any government
support because they're technically
private so what we part we partnered
with an m fi and Ghana to try to create
a program that would make it easier to
lend to these schools because
microfinance institutions tend not to
like to lend to schools they're tricky
loan clients they don't fit well in a
group blending model all of these
reasons and so we developed and then
tested these different loan products and
so there are things like a lot of
proprietors want a loan to buy a school
bus so that they can transport the
children they can get further out and
get kids in more rural areas so it
increases their enrollment and then they
can also rent that bust out during the
school day so it's an income-generating
activity for the school as well and so
and what we liked about using
microfinance
is when you go into these regions you
know extremely rural areas and
sub-saharan Africa you can get
microfinance can go there a lot of other
interventions can't really go very deep
and very far but when you have a loan
officer looking over their loan
portfolio and their school is in that
loan portfolio they're going to go and
monitor that school they're going to
tell you if teachers aren't showing up
they're going to tell you if because if
the school can't repay the loan it's on
their back so that that basically that
feedback mechanism of microfinance is
very well managed much better manage
than the government circulating amongst
the schools and so we thought well let's
let's use that delivery method to bring
some better education into the schools
as well but berichten did you find that
people were surprised that they are
private schools for lower income folks
operating in Africa as a model it's been
such an uphill battle to explain this
sector to people because as soon as you
say the word private school particularly
to somebody from from the West
immediately they don't wanna hear about
it they're like nope school and the
other thing is is that the big debate is
should educate like is free education or
right and we can sure okay it's a right
that it's whose can pay for that
actually somebody's going to pay for it
it's either our tax dollars you know or
coming so what's the the better question
is not should education be free but what
is the most cost efficient form of
education and there have been studies
that show that these low-cost private
schools are cheaper per student for the
same quality of education as the
government-run student schools and so if
that's true then let's use
that delivery method you know or some
some hybrid partnership of a public
private education model